up next we got Brian from Sulphur
Louisiana yang bruh
Eric Griffin's let's see you know it
tastes Rijo gang bruh too much energy
for someone let me know guys keep doing
what you doing much lobe was abuzz gang
bang bang first of all I thought I heard
woman chained up in the back of his
videos it was a little weird it's either
a woman on he's run a slave little too
calm for me that you can tell he's he
would see he parked and stepped into the
back of the house boat van his video in
what was the question
date a blind girl or a deaf girl what
was it so easy death really yeah I got a
do deaf why I'm gonna ruin your whole no
one gonna like you know we don't have to
be honest I would go deaf cuz you wanted
to see things you just don't want the
deaf girl talking all the time first of
all yes I do know what you think
dude you felt for the [ __ ] be honest
Chris and boy damn it and now you're
going down bunny yeah you felt for the
be honest quicksand bro he thought I'm
gonna hold you up in a bucket took you
down boy dude here's the thing blind
girls can just think whatever you want
but you tell them what's going on that's
the thing about blonde you get to be
that liaison you get to be that [ __ ]
color that color donkey form you're
gonna be that the I Walker dog for him
yeah do your [ __ ] Pablo Picasso all
day you know you could describe
something to him if you if you totally
look like Bradley Cooper Baruch like
feel Vaughn do we had a guy a cousin I
think I don't know somebody was [ __ ]
but we told him there were dragons
outside that's fair
and he thought their word dude and until
you seen a blind kid hide from a dragon
you know live bro you haven't seen
anything in an open field
Seiden oh well look man this was a
different times man this one kids you
know kids that you know we're more
imagination you know so I would say
blind if I did date a blind woman or a
deaf woman I think I would prefer blind
because I think they seem more patient
you get to walk them around a little bit
you're taking a baseball games and light
them say it's the night then and what's
the second you could say yes front row
seat take it always be one we won but
she thinks your team's undefeated
yeah my deaf girl might get pissed you
got shitty seats all the time at an
event and you got to learn sign link if
we're gonna go to a female's perspective
would you rather be
would you rather date a blind or deaf
guy I think I'd rather date a deaf guy
personally I just have a deep bass voice
and I love people assume that I'm a
butch woman which is fine perfectly fine
I just think I have better chances of
dating a deaf guy than I would a blind
guy oh wow I don't but the blind guy
might go like this you know I'm saying
like that's how they they feel they just
and they paint but a blog I can also
feel you that's what I'm saying a deaf
guy can also feel you though yeah but he
can see yeah that's true
Derrick what do you think what do you go
blind girls give the best [ __ ] can
they can imagine that dick is anything
baby you know what I mean anything yeah
but bigs big you know I'm saying they
high-five like different [ __ ] little
rats go do you seem high five you
[ __ ] yeah bro you can't high five so
behind people dude it's not cool I know
you're talking about off the whole
culture corner high-five each other with
[Laughter]
God we need chin right now to blast us
off into a different galaxy man but uh
good luck out there and sulfur brother
yeah either blind or deaf good work man
sulfur beautiful city sixty percent went
with deaf as well yes girls yeah that's
tough man when the pine
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching